hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled human monoclonal antibodies for
emerging
agents this webinar is part of a
microbiology virtual week
virtual event and i'm susie valdez of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as
many questions as you'd like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free education credits click
on the continuing
education credits tab located on the top
right corner
of your presentation window and follow
the process to obtain those credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker dr
james crowe the director of vanderbilt
vaccine
center for a complete biography of our
speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr crow welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
hey me and i'm glad to join everybody
today to talk about
human michael antibodies and i think i'm
going to
emphasize it's it's we're having a
microbiology event so i want to
emphasize a subset
of microbiologic agents that are
emerging agents
emerging infections emerging viruses in
particular
and of course this is on everyone's mind
because we're all locked down
in some way because of covid so it's a
very pertinent
area for us so that's that's what we
want to touch on today
you may be living in an environment
where there's a lot of discussion about
personalized or precision medicine
and the idea there is if you study lots
of features
in lots of individuals maybe patterns
will emerge
and we can through systems of discovery
find patterns or pathways that are
interesting
and important and then apply those out
to large populations
but what we've been doing in the history
of biomedical research for
probably over 100 years or what i would
call generalized medicine studies or n
equals one where we take an individual
we study them very carefully uh and we
we
find patterns that we can generalize out
to the population and so this is a
little counter
to the current uh mode or fad of much
research around
precision medicine but i call it n
equals one studies and
and the philosophy is if our genes are
mostly shared then the solutions to many
of our problems can be studied by
in a single patient and this turns out
to be
uh true for monoclonal antibody studies
now this is a high technology field um
the technologies uh for making human
monoclonal antibodies did not exist when
i got into science
uh even i i was doing a postdoc in the
early 1990s and that's when
phage display libraries and other
techniques started becoming available
and we saw a future where human
monoclonal antibodies could be obtained
of course um kohler and milstein got the
nobel prize for their discovery in 1978
of monoclonal antibodies by hybridoma
fusion
but the full um implementation
of monoclonal technologies especially
human molecular
antibodies uh has only occurred in the
last
15 or 20 years now these are now the
most common drugs in the pharmaceutical
pipeline and they're their major
drug categories but mostly for
cancer immunotherapy autoimmune diseases
rheumatoid arthritis things like that
they've not been
used so much in infectious diseases but
i think the tide's going to change
and part of that has to do with the new
technologies that are coming along so
um we're using 10 or 12 different
discovery platforms one of them
uh is a a platform or a pipeline in
which we
string together multiple techniques that
have come
out of uh recent innovative programs so
we can take peripheral blood mononuclear
cells from a human being who's
experienced some infection
any time in their past even 100 years
ago we've done this with 1918 flu
survivors
we can enrich those cells with magnetic
beads or flow cytometry
ultimately going into a single cell
device
we've used 10x genomics berkeley lights
beacon system i'm going to show you
today and other single cell
techniques or even just flows cytometric
sorting into
one's helper well can can work as well
we use specific biosciences or pac bio
sequencing or alumina sequencing
or even other companies but typically
longer arrays if you want full length
we're using
pac bio and if we're using smaller
segments we often use nova seq then bio
for informatics are needed
to sort through all of this sequencing
information and now with synthetic
biology we can make
cdnas and then proteins express those
anabolic proteins do
binding neutralization bowel studies and
non-human primate studies
so that's kind of the pipeline um here's
what it looks like this is
uh a colleague of mine maurice oboji
from
lagos nigeria and he's one of the very
brave physicians who stared down
uh the ebola outbreak that occurred in
nigeria
during the 2014 west african ebola
outbreak
he's a physician and a person came in
infected to his private hospital legos
and he and other
physicians took care of that person
but became infected themselves morris
ultimately
uh survived which is supportive therapy
and uh has told his story a number of
times he came to
our institution at vanderbilt in
nashville tennessee uh to give a
symposium
about his experience not like treating
but also suffering ebola disease and
and surviving so he uh agreed to give us
uh white blood cells we collected by a
process called leucophoresis where we
we filter all the white blood cells that
are circulating at one time we can do it
safely in a hospital environment
and then we have staff who take those
into
biosafety level 2 containment of course
the survivors we're
typically studying are in the
convalescent phase they're not actively
infected
uh they've recovered so there should be
no virus
in their blood samples so we separate
out by gradient
uh the white blood cells by
leukopheresis in the top left you get a
whole bag that might have billions of
cells
but we isolate those and cryopreserve
them
and then use those cells in antibody
discovery
that is as rapid and large scale as we
can
manage and what comes out that back end
are proteins which are monoclonal
antibodies that can be studied
essentially as drugs
from either a basic standpoint to
understand the correlates or mechanisms
of immunity to these diseases
but since we're making them from human b
cells and they're naturally occurring
uh they're really good candidates uh
for use in prophylaxis or therapy and
we've converted this into really kind of
an industrial scale process in some ways
these are just
uh photographs from my phone i just walk
around sometimes and take pictures of
what's going on
so at any one time we probably have over
a thousand human monoclonal antibodies
being made at scale which would be you
know milligram
or even up to gram levels when we need
them for uh
structural studies or non-primate
studies but typically
we're working very high throughput
because not every antibody that you make
is an antibody that would be considered
best in class there's many
uh antibodies that you would make to a
particular target we estimate there
are they're easily we have seen tens of
thousands of
of antibodies to single viral proteins
during response
there's probably more than that we don't
have a an upper bound of what you do but
we sort through thousands during these
antibiotic discovery
campaigns to find the best in class
antibodies
another thing that has helped us a lot
is nextgen
generation sequencing dna sequencing and
also synthetic genomics so these are
fields that have matured
uh ngs really grew out of the human
genome project
and synthetic genomics
you can practically make a mammalian
organism just
by synthesizing dna and going on from
there so
we've been able to do things like synthe
sequence the entire repertoire of
antibody genes or t b cell receptors or
t cell receptors
and a blood sample and what's
interesting about that is
this particular lineage is an influenza
virus
antibody lineage and this little
triangle is the single b cell that we
recovered and we know the function of
this
it's a universal flu antibody that we
discovered
but by sequencing uh the same blood
sample essentially
to depth we see all these somatic
variants and this would be a clonal
lineage
and we can identify uh multiple
instances of some of those somatic
variants and
and also we can infer the uh the
germline or unmutated common
ancestor of these antibodies and once we
know the sequences
we can synthesize them and make them as
proteins and that's that's part of our
workflow
uh so there's sort of two ways to think
about
getting things ready for epidemics or
even pandemics
one is to think ahead of time and be
ready when things happen
so that there's not a scramble and chaos
just to have
uh prophylaxis or therapy available
prior to an outbreak and
then the other philosophy is to develop
technology to move really fast so i'm
going to start with
the idea of thinking ahead of time we've
actually rolled out a program called a
head 100
or advanced human epidemic antibody
defenses for 100 targets
and we've taken everyone's list so
various people have lists the nih sepi
who various um eminent bodies
have published lists and we sort of put
them all together and said okay
we have a meta list and we've been
working on
making human molecule antibodies that
would be
protective or therapeutic for everything
on the list basically
and on the left you see families or
groups of viruses for which we already
have between 50 and up to
probably 5 000 human monoclonal
antibodies and we've down selected to
individual antibody clones that we think
are
sufficient for prophylaxis or therapy
based on
preclinical studies and some of these
are in development or even have been
given in human beings
in the middle we always have uh
campaigns ongoing these are some of the
things we're doing right now on the
right
uh our targets for which we're either
collecting cells or making the antigens
or the assays
we have to do a lot of preparative work
before we pull the trigger to the
campaign because you need
immune donor cells you need a lot of
reagents
you need assays for binding and for
function like neutralization
you need small animal models so there's
a lot of prep work that goes in before
launching
uh but nevertheless we're we're doing a
lot of these campaigns i put my email
address in there the slide because in an
audience like this
there's a very broad community and if
there's something that's not on this
list
and of course we have other targets but
you'd like to see on this list
just ping me and and we'll talk to you
about it particularly if you or someone
you know has
had the target organism that you're
interested in
in the past that makes it even easier
and we can talk with you about
participating in our research
so another area that's greatly impacted
this field not only our work but the
work of
many others are is sort of the
revolution and the efficiency of
structural biology techniques
uh both crystallography and single
particle em reconstructions
uh cryo em uh the the microscopes and
software
uh synchrotron availability all this
stuff is coming together
to allow us to rapidly get structures of
antibodies
in complex with viral antigens or
on viral particles and so these images
are um antibody antigen complexes of
antibodies that we've made in the last
four five years or so uh done with many
collaborators or by ourselves so
a lot of the influenza work we did with
ian wilson's group
and andrew ward's group using
crystallography or em
and field of virus work we did with
erica sapphire's
and a lot of the alpha virus and
flavivirus work we've done
with the purdue group michael rossman
who's
recently deceased and richard kuhn and
others so
and also david fremont at washu so
there's a lot of people who have
expertise in structural biology
and by coupling the antibiotic discovery
uh
with the structural biology we we can
begin to rapidly understand
mechanism of action so that's very
helpful
so i'm going to give you some examples
of this kind of a head 100
philosophy and and rolling out an anime
discovery campaign the first i'm going
to talk about
is marburg virus so marburg is a philoso
it's very similar to ebola uh and it's
not good for you if you get this
so um and this sort of supports
um the idea i talked about if n equals
one so getting
a solution from one person so
um there uh this story is quite
interesting there
was a woman on a street juicing from the
netherlands
who with her partner uh traveled to
uganda
on safari this is a picture of her while
she was on her
uh travel her sort of vacation travel
and she visited a cave
in uganda where fruit bats
congregate there's about 40 000 fruit
bats in this cave and so she visited to
see the animals
and then left the country went back to
the netherlands and
died fairly rapidly afterwards and
marburg virus was isolated
from her blood it turns out that she was
not the first woman to go in the cave
and become ill within a short time
period
this cave uh was sort of a
known tourist site these are the bats in
the on the top of the cave this photo
is actually from joel sartori who's a
national geographic photographer he's a
fantastic photographer
who's photographing most of the animals
on the planet
and he uh also has been to this cave
python cave in uganda and photographed
the rosetta's
aegypticus or the fruit bats so this is
the actual cave where a street went in
and it turns out that investigators from
cdc and other places have gone into the
cave subsequently and demonstrated that
three to five percent of these bats have
marburg virus uh in their body or in
their blood
uh at any one time um so
when the news of a street's uh death
came out in the news and the association
with marburg another person was quite
interested in that news report
and that was michelle barnes michelle
and her
partner husband um also
like to travel to um places to see
animals and unusual things and she had
been
to uganda to the same cave prior to a
street it turns out
michelle had become
similarly infected she had no direct
contact with the vat but
she flew home from uganda became ill no
one could figure out what she had
but uh a number of months after she
recovered with only supportive care
no diagnosis she read about astrid's
case and basically self-diagnosed
herself as having survived marburg
and the cdc then subsequently tested her
serum and she was
marburg seropositive which revealed that
it was what had caused her infection
uh and she gave a tedx talk which is
quite interesting
in which she showed images of antibodies
isolated
from her blood um and you know i
recommend if you're interested to look
at her talk
um so from her
peripheral blood we contacted her she
gave us
uh peripheral blood we made monoclonal
animals from her b
cells and um we made about 50
originally and a number of those were
neutralizing for marburg virus
uh with the with the real virus uh which
we did in
collaboration with alex mcrae at utmb
and in color you see fabs in complex
with
marburg like a protein and each color is
a different
monoclonal antibody and some of them
come in on the left at sort of a 45
degree angle
onto the marburg glycoprotein primer
shown in gray
and on the right there's other
antibodies that come in at a very flat
angle
these are single particle em
reconstructions that were done by daniel
muerin
uh in andrew ward's group had scripts
and when they they revealed that the
antibodies
basically bind to the receptor binding
domain or the inferred receptor binding
domain
on the glycoprotein so this is what i
mean by discovering the mechanism of
action now we know
these antibodies block attachment uh
erica sapphire
uh took several of these this is a an
image from
uh the scripps imaging group and erica
sapphire's group determined
uh the co-crystal structure of the
marburg glycoprotein primer
which is in the the surface
representation in
purple colors in complex with one of the
antibodies in yellow the the darker
yellow is the heavy chain
the the light chain is a lighter yellow
and you can see
that there's a cup shaped pink structure
near the center and the heavy chain cdr3
or the
the complementary determining region 3
or hypervariable
3 reaches down into this cup shaped
structure
which is the receptor binding domain so
this is
a very good outcome for the research
because this was the first
atomic resolution structure of marburg
glycoprotein which had
been elusive in efforts to obtain that
structure just in the apo or on complex
form but in complex with the antibody
erica was able to obtain the structure
so then we knew the structure of
glycoprotein and therefore
the identification receptor binding
domain and we had antibodies
that bound directly to that domain and
that's how they work they block
attachment
and furthermore it's very interesting
if you look at the receptor binding
domain at high resolution and these are
three structures that george gal
put into a cell paper and on the right
is a
structure that we did with erica of the
marburg antibody and complex with
marburg glycoprotein
and orange on the bottom and what we
could see was there were aromatic
residues
on the antibody that reached down and
interacted with aromatic residues on the
marble glycoprotein
well it turns out on the left it was
already known
that another family member ebola
virus like a protein shields the
receptor binding domain
with a structure called the glycan cap
which reaches down and interacts with
the receptor bonding domain and it does
so
with aromatic residues and then george
gauss group in china
and this paper and cell um then
obtained the uh the co-crystal structure
of the npc one
neiman pick c one receptor for filo
viruses in complex with ebola gp
and that receptor also interacts with
ebola gp
uh with aromatics so this is the first
case i'm aware of in which
a viral protein and a human host protein
and an antibody
all use similar uh structural and
biochemical motifs
uh to create pi pi interactions
uh to to
to make the ligand to bind uh and it
also shows that this antibody mimics the
receptor and that's why it's
neutralizing
so that uh one of these antibodies
called mr191
uh has been licensed to a company mount
bio that you may know of from
zmapp uh work so they were very
interested in
filovirus work uh we have studied
um this antibody in monkey
models which are invariably fatal
so this is survival curve and by 10 days
all
untreated animals
are dead with this lethal challenge but
antibody treated animals are all living
so
the united was excited about this and
put out a press release and
and furthermore because of the promise
of this antibody
the united states has a a particular
agency
that supports manufacturing called barda
and you're aware of barda from the news
now
because they they're very involved in
supporting covid
manufacturing efforts so barda
put a significant amount of money in
moving this
antibody marburg 191 into manufacturing
and this
essentially will be the drug uh for
uh marburg that's available and in fact
there was an episode in a containment
lab
where a person was exposed to
marburg and needed to be treated and was
treated with this antibody on emergency
ind
so it just shows you how one person
michelle
the study of her repertoire and making
monoclonal antibodies
can lead to a drug so we michelle as far
as we know
is the only known marburg person
in the western hemisphere
and yeah we could do all that work with
uh just a blood sample from her
now so i mentioned the head 100 program
we don't only want to do marburg we want
to do as many
major pathogenic viruses as possible
now to some extent we've been sort of
reacting to things that have happened
you you know there's been
uh bird flus and zika and chikungunya
and ebola and
you know now soros covey too so we are
doing a head 100 but we typically will
pivot
to do the microorganism that's that's in
the news and
is desperately native for a public
health standpoint so this is a
study that we did published in 2016
of ebola immune donor repertoires and
when we did that this is a circus plot
we actually were looking not only for
ebola zaire reactive antibodies but also
broad uh pan um
pan ebola virus which would be sudam
zaire and budabujo
or panfilovirus which would also include
marburg and we saw reactivity
in three species pretty frequently so
this suggested you could get
a single antibodies that would get all
species of ebola
and maybe that you could make a vaccine
for all three now most of the work in
ebola has been focused on zaire
uh but we made antibodies that were
quite broad
uh again this is single particle em
reconstructions from andrew ward's lab
on the right
showing that many of these antibodies
bind receptor binding domain at the top
but also we got stem or membrane
proximal external region
antibodies on the bottom and a lot of
these energy are very potent
this is a a single
monotherapy using an antibody we made
called ebv
ebov 520
and if we give two doses and a
therapeutic
model on day three and six we get
complete survival
uh even using monotherapy uh which is a
you know a good model uh of what happens
in humans so
um we have uh there are now licensed
antibodies for ebola from
at least for use in
affected areas uh and certainly
antibiotics that have been proven to be
effective from regeneron and
you may know about the map 114 uh
antibody that
was developed by ridgeback and nih and
others so
the principle of using monoclonals is
already out there in humans and
in our case we're now trying to develop
next-gen or second generation
ebola antibodies that are broader that
get not only zaire but also bundaboujo
sudan and are more potent and maybe
could be given later in lower doses
we also worked on zika when that
happened so
we were already working on most of the
flaviviruses
so dengue 1234 and west nile virus
and japanese encephalitis virus
and and other flavia viruses and zika
was on that list even though it only had
been
in uh africa historically and in the
pacific
more recently but then a worldwide
outbreak occurred
uh so we made potent neutralizing human
antibodies for zika
um the neutralization curves are on the
top left and we got
antibodies the pipeline was starting to
mature our experience with it
so we started getting antibodies with
single digit five nanograms
per ml of half maximal inhibitory
concentrations or ic50s
so it does not take much antibody uh
to inhibit the virus and that's what you
want a very very potent
neutralizing antibody when we did
structural studies
uh with uh richard kuhn's group uh we
found that
these antibodies are very you know the
most potent ones are very unusual
uh for instance some of them bridge two
dimers in the flavor virus so they
basically staple
the virus together so it cannot uncoat
we did studies in animal models
including
pregnant models with michael diamond at
washu
and show that passively administered
antibiotics to mothers
even get into the the head
of the fetus and protect the fetus brain
against
virus and this particular antibiotic 117
is now in clinical
development with support from various us
government agencies
and a company called id biologics
this is another example we there's a
virus called
hendra virus so there's a there's a
whole group of viruses
henipa viruses hendra and nipah are the
two
that you've mostly heard about so nipah
has been in malaysia and more recently
in bangladesh
and even kerala area of india causing
outbreaks
so this goes from bats to uh
people or bats to pigs to people
and malaysia hendra is very similar goes
from bats to horses
to humans uh often even to veterinarians
who are caring for the horses
and happens mostly in australia so
hennepin viruses
are are an important potential cause of
epidemics and they're very lethal uh so
we worked with an individual who had
been inadvertently exposed to a horse
vaccine
for hendra so this was not a human
vaccine but the person
inadvertently was exposed to the vaccine
and developed immunity to hendra and
nepa so we identified
um a lot of antibodies the first set
was about 42 antibodies i think and
we've already
shown and this is unpublished work that
we get very potent antibodies
from this individual that neutralize
hendra virus
even this is um
in microgram per ml less than one
microgram per mount we still get a
you know nearly 100 neutralization uh of
hendra
interestingly they also even though they
were induced by hendra
they're very broad in the sense that
some of these also neutralize
nipa virus bangladesh and nipah malaysia
we've done co-crystal structures in our
lab chenwe
dong in our group has gotten co-crystal
structures of a number of these
antibodies so
in yellow and pink you can see the fab
and then green
is um the hendra g protein or the head
domain of the g protein
uh so this antibody binds straight on to
the hendra
g protein which is now also termed the
receptor binding
protein but in gray right here is the
actual receptor so ephraim b2
and e from b3 are the receptors so that
co-crystal structure is known so it
turns out like i showed you before
this is another instance in which the
fab
is binding identically on the same
footprint
as the receptor and therefore that's how
this antibody works it blocks receptor
binding
or blocks attachment and that is a very
potent
method for neutralization now
not all antibodies work by
neutralization which is neutralization
is usually done by mixing
a virus with an antibody for something
like an hour
in vitro and then putting on cells to
see if there's any infectious virus left
some antibodies work by other mechanisms
and by working at scale sometimes we
stumble into these
this is an example of an influenza
antibody
that was quite broad it
recognizes virtually every influenza a
virus
hemoglobin and protein that we've looked
at and if you
look at the top view of this co-crystal
structure
that was done in ian wilson's lab
you can see that the fab so a single fab
was crystallized uh in complex with what
is shown in the ribbon diagram an h a
head domain
but if you represent that complex in the
context of the trimer
so has a trimer there's no way that that
antibody
could bind uh when the ha is in a closed
trimer
because the the epitope for binding on
the ha head domain
is on the inside of the trimmers in the
trimer interface or the interface
between two ha heads at least
and so this is very important because it
reveals that at some point during the
virus life cycle
the h a head domains must open up
and it turns out when we put this
antibody
into neutralization assays it does not
neutralize we do not see
any neutralizing activity for the
antibody which might be discouraging
but we put it into animals we put it in
animals
it protected against viral replication
weight loss
and other disease markers so and it did
that for h1
h3 h5 h7 you know various
subtypes of fluid so this is an example
of a non-neutralizing
antibody that works by a non-canonical
method and i think you're going to see a
lot more of this we've looked at this in
other virus families and
you're going to see a lot more
antibodies to hidden
occult epitopes or what appear to be
occult epitopes
and the interfaces between protomers
that comprise an oligomeric
construct so that's um
that's just kind of the snapshots of
what we're doing by working our head 100
list can we get
important antibodies for as many targets
as possible and to do that methodically
and make thousands of antibiotics and
whittle down the ones that we think
could actually be prophylactic or
therapeutic but um
you know i i raised at the beginning do
you want to plan ahead or
what happens if uh what happens is not
already available is not even on your
list
uh people have sometimes called this uh
agent x
so we need to be able uh to
prepare for things we know about but
also need to be able to respond to
things that we didn't know about or
we weren't prepared for in that case i
think people want to move fast
and there's been a remarkable um
advances in the speed of monoclonal
antibiotic discovery over the last two
years i would say
so we were challenged
about three or so years ago
to develop much speedier platforms by
our participation
in uh what is called the pandemic
prevention platform or p3 program
which was a really a grant call that was
subsequently funded by darpa which is
the defense
advanced research projects agency
and this agency of the u.s government
does not
fund things that can be done if you can
do it they don't fund it
so they would say well the internet that
came out of darpa
funded research it was originally called
darpanet actually if you remember
and gps technology came out of darpa
funding work and
stealth materials and so many
advanced technologies came out of darpa
so they put out a call and said
hey we want um capability
to make a monocle antibody and put it
into human being
60 days after the first case occurs that
was sort of the
model and of course that was ridiculous
at the time
most vaccine projects historically have
taken 20 years or more
most antibody projects take 5 to 10
years and even making uh an expression
line a joe cell line
typically takes 18 months in the
industry
so to say that you would go from
an outbreak or a blood sample to
injecting someone with gmp material in
60 days was ridiculous
but that's the kind of thing that they
they do they put out aspirational goals
so we were selected as one of the four
sites
um the the other three were absera
uh duke university and astrazeneca and
all those sites have been participating
uh in this program including the current
covid um
effort and so what we did to learn how
to do speed we were supposed to be
practicing we're supposed to practice
four times four years in a row
do an all-out effort which we've called
sprints
where you go from start the clock day
zero time
zero a stop watch and then hit the
stopwatch when we're done
so our first big practice run was in
2019
so we started in january and we went
from blood sample
to finish full protection of primates
with an rna that could be used
for clinical trials essentially in 78
days and so i can just
sort of talk you through what that looks
like uh our team
i i didn't i did not agree with this our
team was
excited and fairly confident that they
could
do this first sprint the first target
was 90 days actually
and they thought well we can do this in
90 days and i was skeptical but
to hold ourselves accountable uh we were
tweeting this out live so january 14th
2019 this is pablo gilchuck on day zero
or day one however you want to count it
started sorting in containment blood
samples from a zika immune individual we
use zika
as the model organism for uh to do
this particular sprint we ended up on
the the same day
in a 10x genomics uh platform
uh then we're using liquid liquid
handlers
uh to um make
libraries from single cells
they went to our core labs we did
sequencing our bioinformatics team
processed those immediately we sent
those sequences to a commercial partner
twist bioscience been a great partner
with us
who made um
hundreds of antibody gene cdnas and put
them into vectors by gibson assembly and
shipped them back to us
in essentially you know a week to 10
days
we opened up the fedex box and in 96
we'll format using liquid handlers
we transfected cells within two hours of
receiving
the synthetic genes uh and two days
later we had recombinant antibodies that
we tested for neutralization
now pablo gilchuk in our group uh worked
out
a new method for testing neutralization
so most neutralization tests
take about five days and we couldn't
wait that long in a 60 to 90 days print
you can't spend five days just doing
uh your primary screen so he
and others in our lab developed a
cytopathic effect uh kinetic reading
using a device called excelligence
which is sold by asea and generally this
we put cells in
and there's a electrical sensing of the
cell impedance
which is measures the intact monolayer
of cells and when cells fall apart
the impedance goes down so you can see
cpe the cells are flat
flat and then they crash because we've
added virus but in
and this well flat flat flat the
antibody maintained the integrity of the
cells
so this was a way in which uh in
approximately 18 to 24 hours we can see
the neutralizing effect in a very high
throughput manner this is a 96 wheel
plate there's three 84 well versions
we're using now
and in doing that on the fly we
identified
lots of new neutralizing analyze for
zika
uh we did competition binding
uh on antigen so we could identify uh
groups that competed
for each other which means they're
binding to essentially the same anagenic
site
so we could sort of bend them into
groups which ones are binding
the fusion loop or the domain three or
the domain one two hinge or quaternary
side so we knew
the groups we worked with group integral
moleculars been a good partner with us
they
made alanine mutations at every position
in the zika
envelope protein and uh by looking at
lack of binding to individual members of
that library
we were able to do allen and alanine
scanning during the sprint so we knew
exactly the residues that were important
for escape
we did a series of mouse monoclonal
i mean uh mouse studies with human
monoclonal antibodies
mike diamond conducted these i think
over a 10 to 14 day period
they studied 500 or more mice we
delivered these antibodies we made them
as igg protein
or as messenger rna so the genes
encoding the antibody we did it both
ways
and uh the antibodies that we got were
so good
we actually had to repeat some of these
mouth studies on the fly
this particular study is very stringent
we're only using 0.25 milligrams per
kilogram
um uh
and you know that in typical mouth
studies you would be using 10 milligrams
per kilogram but the
all of our antibiotics worked at that
though so we had to keep
uh dosing down until we could
discriminate and even at a very small
dose
we saw complete protection and then dan
baruch's group
again during the 78 day period
did a subcutaneous antibody
administration the day before challenge
and then challenged with zika virus
and we looked at three different doses
of the lead antibody
two megs per keg point four megs per gig
or
0.08 megs per gig which is 80 micrograms
per kilogram which is extraordinary low
dose and you don't see
any uh zika rna and those animals
whereas the sham
treated animals uh have a nice
replication
curve for a virus so a hundred percent
protection of primates
in uh in 78 days and this work was just
published
this month in nature biomedical
engineering if you want to see how all
that's done
if you want to try it yourself we tell
you exactly how to do this work
at scale and i mean you might say
well rna what's with that you know i've
heard about rna biology but
um that sounds a little pie in the sky
well of course moderna
was actually the first cova vaccine uh
out of the gate
using rna technology in the covet sprint
and they
they've done that based on previous
studies uh but we actually worked with
them
within the context of the darpa program
a previous darpa
program called a debt protect and we
made chikungunya virus
neutralizing antibodies um
as part of that effort and gave them the
genes to moderna
mandarina made them as mrna has actually
completed a clinical trial that started
in february 19
uh and has gone very well so
this is the first instance of a
soluble protein of any kind but
definitely the first instance of
an antibody being delivered as an mrna
and
the antibiotics pressed well and so this
is a promising
new delivery technology that allows
extreme speed so i think
you're not seeing a lot of mrna
antibodies right now but you're going to
see this in the future and it's already
been in man
so then to transition we did sort of the
fake
sprint with zika and i kind of recovered
and we were getting all geared up in
january
um 2020 to do another sprint we were
actually going to simulate a
avian influenza entering the united
states from somewhere in asia that was
our simulation and
we were just about ready to go to spend
uh
you know a couple months doing that full
out and
essentially uh right right in the middle
of our preparations
source cov2 happened uh and you remember
this is the new england journal report
which states on january 19th of this
year the first case
uh that was known at the time the first
identified case
uh was a man who walked into a clinic
near seattle uh we decided to pivot and
work on source cov2 immediately and
in consultation with our uh darpa
sponsors
and so by seven days later on january
26th
from the time the person walked in uh
fedex
staff member delivered to my home on
sunday morning in nashville tennessee a
blood sample from the first case so we
we immediately launched uh
switching on the fly and the problem was
we didn't have any reagents
we had some blood and no reagents and no
assays and we didn't have any time to
prepare
fortunately during this epidemic and
pandemic
many investigators have released
information very rapidly
so the sequences came out of the spike
protein
and then many in the field made
structures
uh so jason mcclellan made structures
very early on and released them
which revealed the receptor binding
domain and even the
receptor binding motif the internal
domain
and the open and closed forms and i was
determined very rapidly ace2 was the
receptor and the complex of that was
understood
so that gave us a blueprint for what to
do
so that was very helpful so we built
assays while we were doing the work on
the fly
to use that information for instance
using streptavidin and beads
making uh either the the receptor
binding domain as a reagent or the
full-length spike protein or the active
domain and spike protein
and recombinant ace2 with the tag
and we could build uh assays by labeling
antigen
and identifying antigen-specific b cells
by flow cytometric sorting so we we
sorted
angin-specific cells spike or rbd cells
activated them in vitro and then we work
with berkeley lights in this case
uh on their beacon instrument which was
a fantastic collaboration
so this is a high throughput single cell
device and the way this works is
if we have a bead and a single cell
secretes an antibody
and we can detect that antibody captured
on the bead
we can see these in single cell cultures
essentially
so single cells are deposited and
the antibody spills out into a main
chamber almost like
a volcano and so you can you can sit and
watch the live cells making antibodies
fantastic
and we even developed a neutralization
assay
surrogate using single cells which is a
blocking
of the interaction of the receptor
binding domain with ace2 which simulates
the virus binding to the receptor
and so we could demonstrate and you can
see here the little pens
with a single cell at the bottom we
could demonstrate
that some of the antibodies bound the
receptor
binding domain but did not block binding
but some of the
the cells were we're making an antibody
that did bind to the receptive bonding
domain but the
h2 did not bind in the presence of
antibiotics so essentially we did a
single cell neutralization
for the first time that i'm aware of now
i already mentioned that
in our workflow you can take single
cells by berkeley lights we also did
parallel workflow
as i've shown you before with 10x
genomics and then again pac bio
or alumina sequencing we sent those
sequences to twist bio
who sent us back again just as i
described and this is now a 384 well
uh real time neutralization assay and
again pablo gilchuk worked this out with
says zost in our
group and was able to do dilutions of
antibodies during screening one to
twenty one to a hundred one to fifty one
and twenty five hundred
and here you can see impedance goes up
and then add virus
and then impedance goes down and so in
this case these four
quadrants uh these cells uh were
infected
but in this green case uh impedance
continues to go up even the presence of
virus
out to one to one hundred but fails at
one to five hundred
so we were able to determine potency
during screening
at high throughput right off the first
expression which was
uh really fantastic cut a lot of time
out
so then because these are recombinant we
can put them into
what is ultimately a manufacturing cell
line a chosen line
and we screen them not only in the ways
that i showed you but also an elisa
against full length s protein
against the receptor binding so it's
subset by an rbd
some bind the n terminal domain and we
also looked at stars
one because we were interested in
cross-reactive antibodies with sars and
mares
and then uh neutralization assays were
done with real virus in biosafety level
three with michael diamond's lab
also with ralph baer lab at unc for
confirmation
and we see with multivirus
we have antibodies that are down into
the
nearly 10 nanogram per ml ic50 range so
against multivirus
and just a caveat that uh if you use
pseudaviruses where you take vsv
uh and you you put source cov2 on on a
pseudo virus
uh the pseudoviruses uh overestimate the
potency so
the same antibodies that are uh 10 or
100 are
less than one in a pseudovirus so i
think you need to be careful when you're
looking at neutralization assays
very grateful to the washu team this is
pictures of them
brett and swathi or some of the team
members there who worked in the bsl3 and
animal bso3
facilities even during the whole
lockdown and we were able to
rank antibodies in terms of
neutralization h2 binding
or blocking and then binding to rbd or
the ectodomain
and and by doing all of these assays
very rapidly
we could identify potency we again did
competition binding and found
various groups that competed and we
could interpret those
uh using alanine scanning again uh uh
has
in terms of where these things were
binding uh on the spike protein
and we even went one step further during
this particular sprint
and we took two uh antibody combinations
that each antibody recognized the rbd
but we're not
competing for binding and this is
actually a single particle em
reconstruction we did in the lab
um a lot bench teen in our lab did this
on trimer
and you can see these two antibodies can
simultaneously bind and we looked at
neutralization as you do dilutions
of one antibody and the other together
in combinations we can detect synergy
occurring with the two
so this is a really beneficial effect of
a combination they're not only additive
and resist
escape but we actually get synergy which
is a desirable property
uh mike diamond and uh ralph barrick's
lab have put these antibodies into mouse
models even
either through adenovirus transduction
or
transgenics or other methods
and these analyze work in vivo and mass
models
and even you know against virus or
histopathology
and then again uh dan baruch's lab
worked with us on non-human primate
studies
in which either one of these two
antibodies that came out of the sprint
um were used as monotherapy
and ice type control you see lots of
irish shedding we don't see a single
molecule of rna and the nasal swab or
the bronchial reveal or lavage
in either of these monotherapy
situations so these were nominated as
frontline drug candidates and just to
kind of think through what i just showed
you happened
uh we got a sample ultimately that gave
us
um the lead candidates we received that
sample
in nashville on march 14th ultimately
we did a sprint over 25 day period and
then
transferred the sequences to pharma
partner astrazeneca
and august 25th they started phase one
trial
we've already published most of the
stuff i showed you during that spread
and nature nature met if you want to
look at that but a phase one
trial in august 25th from uh efforts
where we got the sample on march 14th uh
was really pretty rapid so we're doing
more animal studies
accumulating structures we're working
not only with astrazeneca but other
partners to
further some of these uh they're being
developed
in cho cells and plant expression and
tobacco and also as mrna
these antibodies have been been
incorporated in diagnostic kits
and vaccine companies are using these
antibodies to characterize various lots
of their vaccines to show that they
contain conformational epitopes so in
summary what i showed you
today is the first half we can prepare
ahead of time by making lists of things
that are likely to happen
but in the back half of the talk i said
well we can discover analyze really fast
uh and these approaches enable us to get
into clinic
rapidly so antibodies off of these
platforms have already been into people
for chikungunya marburg source cov2
and others are bumping along in the
pipeline i do think in the future you're
going to see mrna
as a delivery mechanism certainly going
to be studied
and has promised to work as a fast
delivery
system and also you've heard lots about
vaccines and antivirals
and i think increasingly what you're
going to find is antibodies are going to
become the
the future of preventing and treating
infectious diseases one thing i didn't
mention is
um most of the trials that are being
done certainly with animals that we've
developed with
various partners have long half-life
mutations
and so some of the the actual molecules
are predicted
to have a half-life of 60 to 90 days but
the protective effect
could be projected as long as a year or
maybe even two we'll have to see from
the trials
but when you start getting in into
potential protection for a year
this is going to be competitive with the
type of protection you see from vaccines
so
increasingly antibodies are going to be
important in the space
and i've tried to mention collaborators
we worked with along the way
diamond barrick baruch dr lee's lab at
emory and
helen chu at seattle i have worked with
us
on samples and assays as
mario ostrowski who provided the samples
that
led to the lead drug candidates we've
worked with some great companies
berkeley lights the beacon i showed you
twist and the synthesis 10x genomics
work with us and these two companies id
biologics and astrazeneca are developing
uh clinical uh source cov2 we had
support from
american in europe mayor kgaa and
darvstad germany
with the future inside prize uh erica
sapphire and wilson andrew ward
alex mccraeff folks at integral
the mrna work we did for zika was done
with idri
uh in seattle and folks at moderna and
we've gotten funding from darpa but also
the nih
and being in nashville um you know it's
a music capital dolly parton
lives here uh and dolly parton made a
lead gift to vanderbilt to support
research early on the outbreak you know
to make a point of hope and we benefited
some from that
so thank you very much i'm happy to
answer questions
thank you dr crow for that informative
presentation and we will now start
the q and a portion of the webinar if
you have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen dr crowe we have a
quite a lot of questions coming in and
we'll try to get
as many as we can and any questions not
answered
will be answered via email first
question
what about anti-body from suspect
covid19
tell us a little bit
antibody from suspect
i i don't fully follow the questions say
it again
yeah what about um the audience members
says
what about the antibody from
um this from suspect covid19 or perhaps
maybe they're saying
do you suspect a certain antibody from
kubin19 or
not exactly sure how the question would
you like to answer that one via email
um sure i i
don't fully fully follow that question
all right
perfect um our next question is what
steps do you and your lab group take to
assure the safe
antibody treatment for pathogens and
viruses
so safety is is paramount we
are basically a discovery unit we do not
do manufacturing and we don't do trials
so
we license our antibodies out um
or provide them to various parties and
and they're
they're mostly focused on safety but
things that are done
toxicity testing is done in good
laboratory environments it's very
expensive
it's typically done in rabbits and
primates
tissue cross reactivity is examined so
antibodies are put on
all sorts of human tissues to make sure
that none of the
analytes are autoreactive or bind any
tissues um
and we also try to look at the predicted
half-life
in especially non-human primates because
you can get anti-drug
antibodies uh which would make antigen
antibiotic complexes
antibody antibiotic complexes which is
not good for you and also reduce half
life
so there are a lot of things that go on
during the early development stage
after discovery for safety purposes
thank you for that and we're
unfortunately getting closer to the end
of the time
i just want to ask one more question
before we go and give you time to have
some closing remarks
what is the difference between a wild
type virus
and a pseudo virus
that's a good question so the viruses
that are circulating in people
would be field strains once they're into
a lab and you've cultured them in cells
people
people call those isolates and they may
change in culture
but typically people also often will
call those
wild type viruses because they don't
change very much in culture
so that's a virus that you would use in
the biosafety level three if you take
another virus
that's not pathogenic for humans or less
pathogenic
such as vesicular stomatitis virus or
you could use
a debilitated hiv and you could take out
the
the naturally occurring surface protein
of the virus and swap in
source cov2 or some other virus that
becomes a pseudovirus
but usually they're debilitated by
deletion of an internal gene
so they can't make more virus they just
they they work as particles
so they can go in a cell and make a
signal but no virus comes out they're
much easier
safer to work with and and we work in a
biosafety level two lab
we don't work in biosafety level three
or four we do that with partners
so we oftentimes will use these
pseudoviruses that mimic the virus
but can be used at biosafety level too
and that's been very helpful to the
field
wow this is incredible stuff and i just
want to thank you again for your
presentation would you
like to provide our audience members
with any closing remarks before we go
um i just like to say it's been a an
amazing experience to
work on antibodies i've been in this
field for 25 years
and to see the acceleration what i
showed you today is our work in our lab
with
many collaborators and partners but if
you look at what's happened with source
code v2
there's already uh antibody programs um
i mentioned ours with astrazeneca's in
the clinic but regeneron
lily veer various uh
corporate partners have manufactured
animals and already gone into trials
coming from a variety of sources and
there are
efforts in china and in europe that are
similar so
just really really exciting to see the
impact
of antibody technologies during this
pandemic and i just can only believe
this is going to go faster
bigger easier and it's just really
encouraging to me
that antibodies may be a major part of
the solution for epidemics and pandemics
in the future so
i hope you enjoy it i'd love to see more
people get into this field it's really
exciting field
thank you so much and thank you again
for your time today and for your
important research fascinating research
really
um before we go i also want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via your contact information you
provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months so up to march of
2021 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
take care be safe stay healthy bye
everyone